Speaker 1: Well, big shocker, guys. The
number of assault rifles being purchased
since the recent shootings in Texas and in
Buffalo and in Tulsa and all the other places,
the number of assault rifles being purchased
is exploding. And it is a veritable domestic
arms race that is being faced here. And this
should come as no surprise to anyone who's been
watching this show, listening to the podcast
for a while. This is what happens when there
are shootings and this is what happens when
there are not shootings. I'll explain in a
moment. Let's go to a video from a gun
shop in Georgia where the owner says
assault rifle sales are off the charts and
it's thanks to Biden. Take a listen to this.
Speaker 2: The way this presidents
are driving this country,
everybody needs to be caring at this point.
Speaker 3: But a firearm superstore in Smyrna.
Sales are up 30% since last week. Assault
rifle sales have tripled, says Eric Walz.
Speaker 4: And especially first
thing this morning. A lot of folks
were waiting at the door to purchase a AR 15.
Speaker 3: AR 15 bands have dominated discussions
about gun sale restrictions in light of their use
in recent mass shootings across the country. Yet
the assault rifles deadly qualities are also what
draws gun enthusiasts seeking a self-defense tool.
Speaker 4: If you're dealing with a mob of people
that are trying to possibly take over your home,
you're going to need and to protect your
family, you're going to want as much
firepower as you can get. So I think it'd
be a great choice. But why get an AR 15?
Oh, well, it's America's rifle.
Speaker 3: Trevor Gagne walked
out of the store with a new AR 15.
Speaker 4: This is a good choice.
You know what America is? Americans
choose to defend their homes with the.
Speaker 3: Trigger, buying it for home defense.
Speaker 4: Not really. There's more of us.
More of a collector's item under.
Speaker 1: Imagine that.
Imagine that with anything is. Oh, wow.
That's a nice knife. Why this one? Well,
it's the best knife for cutting. Oh, you're going
to buy it for cutting things? No, no, no. It's
just a collectible. I don't actually plan to use
it. Wait, why? Huh? What are you talking about?
Speaker 3: Damage. Some buyers
say there is room for greater
government control over the sales of firearms.
Speaker 4: I think we do have to have to have
more stringent laws when it comes to keeping
guns out of the hands of the mentally ill.
This is crazy what's going on right now.
Speaker 3: But others view compromise
on gun laws as dangerous.
Speaker 2: If we give up our Second
Amendment rights and just put the handcuffs on.
Speaker 1: Right. It's like being in jail. If you
can't have any gun you want at any time with no
oversight. It's like being in a prison now. This
shouldn't surprise us. I've said a million times
more shootings generate gun sales in the following
way. There's basically three scenarios. Okay.
You've got more shootings that make national news
and a Democratic president. Well,
you'd better go out and get those guns
because it's really dangerous out there. And
the Democratic president is coming for your
guns. They never end up coming for the guns, but
that's the story. So you've got shootings and a
Democratic president increases in gun sales. If
you've got shootings and a Republican president,
then the Republican president will openly
say people should be defending themselves.
It's dangerous out there. So more shootings in a
Republican president also generate more gun sales.
And on the off chance that we have a decrease
in shootings or a temporary lull, although
that's not very common in the United States, I
mean, we just have shootings all the time. But
if we did, even on a localized level, then income
the gun. Gun lobbies and they go, this is thanks
to people having guns. It is safer now because
people have guns. So if you like that there are
fewer shootings, if that would ever happen, you'd
better go and get yourself the guns, because the
more guns you have, the safer you will be. So it
doesn't happen. It doesn't matter what happens in
the real world in all three scenarios. More guns
is what the gun lobby pushes and the gun dealers
and the gun manufacturers, no matter what, they
justify it. And this is what we call. You come
to your conclusion first and then you find a
different way to justify it. We want more guns.
We can either justify it by saying more guns
have costs because shootings do decline. So
keep getting them or you need guns
because it's dangerous out there
as evidenced by all these shootings.
Either way, the solution is more guns.